[Musique]
justin mercier cause recteur du réseau
d' analyse stratégique est professeur
titulaire de science politique à l'uqam
charles philippe david président
fondateur de l'observatoire sur les
états-unis à la chaire raoul dandurand
bonsoir à vous deux
oui ben il ya eu vraiment beaucoup de
mouvements encore une fois dans ce
chapitre de la guerre en ukraine cette
semaine moscou qui a confirmé ce matin
avoir bel et bien frappé kiev hier en
pleine visite du secrétaire général de
l'onu alors des fois qu'ils ont été
condamnés aujourd'hui de toutes parts
jean-philippe d'avec elin message à
votre avis que la russie a voulu envoyer
avec cette frappe la
fin je pense qu'on va tous être d'accord
pour dire qu'un volume que ce message
qui est envoyé c'est que vladimir
poutine au fond ne passe pas grand chose
de la communauté internationale et des
règles qui ont prévalu on va dire dans
les dernières décennies et que l'onu n'a
pas vraiment un rôle important à jouer
et d'autant que l'onu a condamné
évidemment l'invasion de l'ukraine par
par la russie est donc cet affront pour
moi s'ajoute à la longue longue liste de
cette attitude ou de ce comportement
tout à fait dictatorial de la part de
poutine il est seul selon lui maître à
bord et les négociations en plus le
message que cela envoie c'est que la
diplomatie n'a pas vraiment sa place
actuellement hormis si évidemment et
lady qui obtempère aux conditions à
toutes les conditions que lui imposerait
la dîmière poutine et que l'occident a
aussi appuyé ces conditions là ça ne se
fera pas donc dans ce contexte là il l'a
dit d'ailleurs le week-end dernier
claire map la diversité dati se il n'y a
plus de place il n'y a plus de teint
pour la diplomatie donc on attend le
résultat de cette guerre et on atteint
et il attend certainement de voir que
ces troupes l'emportent au moins dans
l'est et dans le sud de l'ukraine à
défaut d'avoir gagné
kiev est d'avoir gagné le nord de
l'ukraine qu'il puisse au moins obtenir
cela de son pointu donc la perspective
que gutierrez négocier un cessez-le-feu
ou encore de lui accorder une place
importante à l'onu n'est pas vraiment sa
priorité selon moi donc aucun résultat à
prévoir nous de ces rencontres de goûter
res avec vladimir poutine
avec volodymyr ski même pas non plus
pour l'évacuation des civils qui sont
toujours piégées à mariupol
bah si vous me posez la question je sais
pas si tu as juste que voulait la poser
mais pour l'instant les couloirs
humanitaires écouter dire que c'est
laborieux c'est un euphémisme c'est je
ne sais plus combien de promesses on est
rendus de 2,2 d'essayer de trouver une
façons par lesquelles les civils peuvent
être évacués en toute sécurité sans
devoir subir de tirs d'artillerie de bus
ou de bombardements et ça se produit je
vous le dis laborieusement et c'est bien
que des reins marioupol je pense qu'on
en est à une demi douzaine de promesses
qui ont été faites depuis une semaine et
pas une fois vraiment on a vu la
situation
s'améliorer pour lessiver il ya toujours
je sais pas exactement où on en est mais
environ cent mille civils qui sont
prisonniers à marioupol ya toujours les
militaires ukrainiens qui sont là dans
le site industriel que les ruches
continue malgré les promesses de poutine
de suspense des bombardements il ya eu
encore apparemment un bombardement hier
donc la situation est terrible pour les
civils une inacceptable je sais mais si
on avait surtout les yeux en direction
du dôme basses ces derniers temps le
pentagone qui a déclaré cet après midi
que la russie prend du retard en raison
de la résistance ukrainien de la retard
par rapport à son propre calendrier
est-ce que c'est où vous aussi votre
analyse des situations c'est exact et
c'est en grande partie grâce aux armes
que l'otan fournit que les états unis le
canada l'europe fournit du crédit qui a
permis de résister à ces enfants là et a
limité les gains qu'ils sont il y en a
eu des gagneuses minimum et icône
énormément cher à l'armée aux rênes de
personnel et dick mac sont détruits
alors on peut penser que ça va prendre
plusieurs semaines encore que cette
annonce poursuivre reprendre les
stratégies sont basses et c'était un
premier bombardement on a parlé tout à
l'heure de ce bombardement à kiev
pendant la visite du secrétaire général
de l''onu premiers bombardements depuis
la mi avril dans la capitale
est ce que vous y voyez
une stratégie militaire ou une
provocation
je pense que le message qu'ils veulent
envoyer c'est que ça va frapper partout
en ukraine et elle veut aussi discuter
les forces de l'otan de continuer à
donner sur ce matériel là on veut
diviser les opinions publiques on veut
créer ou dans le monastère nucléaire
pour limiter cet approvisionnement qui
est crucial à la résistance ukrainien et
le message qu'on dit c'est que peut-être
les forces terrestres
tout les droits mais limitée frappé
l'ouest de l'art le sud le centre et
c'est le message qu'ils en parlent
beaucoup d'armements fournis par
l'international jean-philippe les états
unis ont allongé salah pense maintenant
ajouté 33 milliards de dollars c'est ce
qui a été annoncé par dubaï dernière
pour aider l'ukraine
j'ai presque le goût de dire que la
semaine qui vient de se terminer et
consacre presque le changement dans
cette guerre d'une guerre russie et
régionales avec l'ukraine en
confrontation franchement et directe
entre les etats-unis et la russie
évident avec les alliés aussi de
l'ukraine en europe et le canada
notamment mais je pense que joe biden a
augmenté sérieusement l'implication des
états unis dans cette guerre par son
annonce qui écoute et multiplie par 8
des engagements déjà qu'il avait pris et
que le congrès des stages y avait pris
pour soutenir l'ukraine 33 milliards
c'est énorme comme comme comme aide
évidemment lieu de l'aide économique et
l'aide humanitaire mais il faut savoir
que trois cars de crs et une aide
militaire directe comme l'a dit juste
est pour venir en aide à l'armée
ukrainienne on pourra résister à
l'offensive russe et de son côté poutine
évidemment la seule stratégie qui
fonctionne c'est une stratégie presque
de terre brûlée comme il l'a déjà
pratiqué en tchétchénie comme il l'a
pratiqué en syrie c'est à dire de
détruire les infrastructures ukrainienne
de chasser d'ici vl parce que son
offensive sur le plan strictement
militaire
pas de l'ale elle n'a pas réussi dans le
nord ni autour de la capitale elle a
fait des progrès dans le jeu et dans
l'est de l'ukraine mais si ses
approvisionnements hawks dando et
surtout américains parviennent
rapidement à aider l'armée ukrainienne
il est bien possible qu'on assiste plus
à une impasse des avancées et des reculs
de la part de la russie dans le sud et
dans l'est qu'une victoire franche une
victoire décisive de l'armée russe pour
acquérir tout l'est de l'ukraine et au
fond procéder à une sorte de partition
de fait de ce pays où la russie par avec
un morceau important que tout le monde a
entendu le donbass et laisse le reste de
l'ukraine à zellik ski parce qu'ils ne
peuvent plus espérer gagner toute
l'ukraine alors oui en effet ça risque
de durer un bon moment je pense
plusieurs semaines peut-être même plus
encore le secrétaire général de l'otan a
parlé de moi qui n'aime ni même tout à
fait bien que tombé en bas de ma chaise
oui dunga qui pourrait durer plusieurs
années alors on va voir mais il est
clair que l'implication américaine dans
le soutien l'armée ukrainienne on parle
l'imaginé de possiblement ces armes
qu'ils puissent se rendre en trois jours
c'est g un très peu de temps ça je suis
là dit mr poutine va réagir aussi à tous
à tous c'est elle qui a été annoncé
jusqu'à et merci est-ce qu'on s'approche
effectivement là de plus en plus d'une
guerre par procuration
comme le disait jean philippe david et
comme le prétend le kremlin également
oui absolument je suis d'accord avec
jean david assez clairement on se dirige
vers une impasse ou par procuration
virus ne peuvent poster remède est un
succès vladimir poutine vraiment
qualifie ce bien existentielle pour la
sécurité nationale russe ne peut pas se
permettre la tâche est donc qu'il lui
reste comme monty seller scalable il ya
deux types descarie présentement avec
les menaces de scrat nucléaire mais il
ya d'autres options ou six ans sur la
table et l'une qui va être possiblement
considéré à la russie ce sera celle de
la mobilisation générale de la
population a augmenté les forces
militaires
vous pensez qu'on va mobiliser les
russes eux-mêmes pour les entraîner dans
cette gamme
c'est-à-dire les russes ont perdu des
milliers sinon des dizaines de milliers
de soldats n'ont pas la capacité
militaire
cette offensive le contenu de la
résistance ukrainien et le les options
c'est top et ses contingents la
augmenter la conscription qui est fait
en russie pour aller construire la
totalité ou une grande partie de la
population pour pas augmenter les forces
militaires russes pour avoir plus de
médailles
de poursuivre cette offensive
mais bien sûr il ya un danger avec ça et
le risque c'est de revivre l'expérience
de l'afghanistan qui a duré presque dix
ans où beaucoup de conscrits furent
mises à contribution pour soutenir
l'armée russe est là bien sûr si la
russie ne gagne pas je veux bien croire
que la stratégie du mensonge de poutine
puisse fonctionner hélas un bon bout de
temps que mettons deux tiers trois
quarts de sa population achète le
message que ce qui ce qu'il fait en
ukraine est justifiée mais à un moment
donné il aura des comptes à rendre je
peux pas croire que ça ne se sort pas
que beaucoup de soldats russes meurent
au combat réputé des genres on ne peut
pas évidemment affirmé que les chiffres
sont avérés mais si les chiffres
minimalement de 15000 voire jusqu'à
25000 jeunes ce qui at il affirmé
soldats russes ont péri en ukraine mais
c'est quand même des chiffres
astronomiques donc je pense que plus la
guerre doit durer longtemps il ya aussi
le risque pour poutine qu'ils ne
puissent pas affirmé le 9 mai lors de sa
grande parade pour célébrer la seconde
guerre mondiale la victoire russe la
victoire soviétique à l'époque il ne
pourra peut-être pas affirmé qu' il a
gagné son plan de bataille où son combat
en ukraine alors il ya un risque quand
même à terme pour lui mais dans
l'immédiat bien sûr ça n'aide pas la
cause de sauver épargner les civils de
toutes ces dommages de ces destructions
qui sont infligées sur les
infrastructures les villes ukrainiennes
et comme l'a dit juste l escalade est
possible et j'en ajouterai eu ce qu'on a
vu en transnistrie le week end dernier
pourrait bien se reproduire
et qui sait si poutine pourrait ne pas
être attiré par un élargissement du
conflit
quoique cela lui coûterait cher sur le
plan logiciel vous dans un petit pays
comme la moldavie est placée encore
l'otan dans une position évidemment
délicate alors voyez tout est sur la
table encore tout est envisageable avec
lui oui
effectivement et je sème ainsi croyez
vous qu'il ya des risques réels de
débordements justement là en moldavie
notamment à l'extérieur donc de
l'ukraine il faut comprendre que la
quantité trop heureuse présentement
transmis cité c'est quand même si on
parle dans des ondes mais là les deux
sens autant ce n'est pas une force qui
est suffisant de votre front à l'ouest
de dessins qui pourrait permettre dans
un sorte que cette ville et on les pose
la
provision là parce qu'ils doivent aller
au dessus
la moldavie ou de l'ukraine donc je
crois que ça fait plus partie du mérite
or et que de réels probabilité sur le
terre parce que compte tenu des excès
dans l'est du pays je pense que les
ressorts a tout intérêt à concentrer
leur attention dans cette région dont
basse et ouvrir un autre front qu'ils
auraient des difficultés à avaler et
pendant ce temps là bon aujourd'hui on
parlait également du prochain sommet du
g20 qui va avoir lieu en novembre en
indonésie
les deux présidents poutine et zielinski
ont été invités ce qui fait pas les
affaires des états unis joe biden qui a
déclaré qu'il ferait pas semblant de
rien en terminant là dessus j'ai fait
les plus vives vous attendez à quoi
concernant g20 je m'attends à une
confrontation diplomatique parce qu en
effet l'humeur est très mauvaise à
washington sur la tenue de ce sommet les
mutations qui était de rester à poutine
donc je matin de forte représentation
américaine est probablement certaines
déclarations assez intempestives qui
puisse être prononcée de la partie prise
d'un texto gidon suivent parce que comme
je dis sur le plan diplomatique la les
lueurs d'espoir sont très très ténue oui
beaucoup de réactions à suivre bien sûr
par rapport à sa chance et david et
justin et massy merci beaucoup à vous
d'avoir été là
alors bon week-end à tous à vous aussi